[Music]
i'm dave sassen alongside jeff worthing
and welcome to the 2013 east west pole
where we're going to be watching some of
the best college athletes in the nation
try to put last year's spectacle to
shame that's right dave it won't be easy
but this year's seniors certainly will
be trying to give last year's stars a
run for their money let's check out the
team starting with the players from the
east
[Music]
cos nestor smith right kiss university
ellipses quarter university of alabama
now aquila's deal wide lsu
bismo funyuns
florida state university decathlon mango
georgia tech university america troy
schedule
university of louisville
chris netan business university of
tennessee the parish poop shed
ole miss crocodile blip
auburn university ghoulies boozler
the you miscatene tristan
university of michigan
fall
university of arkansas blarong
washington
co2 cartoons plural virginia tech jammy
jimmy jammy
v
ohio state university
fudge
some of the big stories this year the
meteoric rise of de pez poopsie and
let's not forget about heisman winner
jammy jammy jammy and remember you can't
talk about 2013 without bringing up
fudge everybody's talking about fudge at
350 pounds this running back is almost
unstoppable the whole year you're right
i could talk about fudge all day but
first let's meet the players from the
west
[Music]
equine ducklings
indiana university purdue university
indianapolis dar historianist la
mistorious utah state university
iwakonias sigourneth junior steam
oklahoma state university exquisite team
buble schwenslow university of nebraska
hukalakanaka hakanaka hika lukahuka
kafaka university of hawaii king prince
chambermaid
baylor university the jennifer jedanna
sting
university of colorado
university of arizona harvard university
devry universities
rv
navy surplus store
wingdings
online classes
first name last name
college university god
home school
squeeze
santa monica college
benedict cumberbatch
oxford university
a.a ron belake morehouse college